大家好 欢迎来到数据要素可信流通技术的牧客
我是来自浙江大学的博士后研究员杨云博
我将给大家带来让数据可流通、可验证、不可泄漏
关于零知识证明在区块链中的应用探索
我将从这三个角度来给大家介绍
零知识证明的一些应用场景和它的一些背景知识
首先是出探零知证明
随后是零知证明、负能区块链
最后是零知证明在区块链上的一些应用
那么首先我将会给大家带来什么是零知识证明
那么零知证明的定义如下所示
零知证明系统当中通常有两个参与方
分别叫做验证方和证明方
证明者会持有一些隐私数据W
我们在英语当中可以记作为Witness
然后私有数据的有效性可以由一些函数或者验证来得到
那么如图所示证明者手里面持有一个W
然后它需要向验证方去证明
这个W会扔到这样的一个函数当中F
会得到相应的FW等于1
然后在这里面证明者会向验证者去生成一个证明派
这个派可以让验证方很快地去验证说W和F之间的一个关系
那么零知证明当中需要满足三个重要的一个性质
首先是协议的一个正确性
然后是协议的一个可靠性
那么协议的可靠性就要求了如果说输入是无效的
那么对应的这样的一个派它也是一个无效的验证
也就是说这样的一个prove是不能通过检验的
最后一个是一个可选的一个性质叫做零知识性
那么零知证明当中这个零知识性指的是
验证者无法从对应的这样的一个prove当中获取任何有关Witness的一个信息
那么零知证明的一个通俗定义
在于它是一个密码学研究的一个重要分支
它是拥有私有数据的证明者
可以在不泄漏任何关于私有数据的一个信息的情况下面
向验证者证明数据的一个有效性
那么零知证明它可以实现的是一个数据可用不可见的一个数据安全管控
它也是数据流通当中的一个安全技术
主要用于可验证计算
那么接下来我就会给大家用一个简单的例子来介绍一下零知证明
那么最有名的一个是对应的阿里巴巴动学问题
那么在阿里巴巴动学问题当中经常就是说有一个故事
也就是说阿里巴巴和应该是七个大道的一个故事
也就是说阿里巴巴知道在动学当中
它里面存有保障了这个门的一个钥匙
但是如果说阿里巴巴直接把这个钥匙给到七个大道
然后把门打开
那么这个时候就会有一个问题
就是说阿里巴巴这个人就没有任何的利用价值了
然后这些大道就会把阿里巴巴这个人给干掉
那么在这个情况下面如何保证说阿里巴巴能够成功的通过验证
同时不泄露对应的这样的一个钥匙
也就是打开这算门的一个秘密
那么我们在这里就是有这样的一个故事作为一个背景的铺垫
那么在这里面我们如左图所示
假设Alice是在这里面抽象为七个大道
Bob在这里面B点是Bob
就抽象为阿里巴巴
他知道C和D点之间的一个钥匙
但是Bob不希望将像Alice去透露这样的一个钥匙是长成什么样子的
所以Bob和Alice就需要通过一个0G证明的一个手段
去证明
去向Alice去证明Bob他手里面确实是有这样的一个钥匙
那么怎么样去实现这样的一个过程呢
其实很简单
首先我们可以让Bob
Alice可以让Bob从任意的一个点
可以从任意的一个位置进入到对应的一个位置
比如说Alice让Bob从C点进去
然后如果Bob他里面有对应的一个钥匙
他就可以打开C点和D点之间的这样的一扇门
然后Alice要求他从对应的这个D点跑出来
那么如果说Bob他确实能够从D点跑出来
那么就说明他以很大的概率持有这一把钥匙的
那么每一次Bob可以去从对应的C点和D点出来的一个概率
如果他手里面不持有钥匙
他的一个概率是一分之一
这个就取决于Alice让Bob对应的从哪一个点出来
是从对应的C点出还是D点出
那么如果说这样的一次实验的一分之一的概率是比较大的
那么我在这里面的Alice可以让Bob去重复这样的一个实验
也就是说Bob可以从任意的一个C点进或者D点进
但是Alice可以让他从任意的一个C点出或者D点出
那么如果说Bob每一次都可以从对应的一个位置出来
那么Bob就可以以很大的概率是具有这样的一个钥匙的
也就是说对应的是前面的一个重要的一个性质
也就是对应的一个协议的一个可靠性
那么在整个协议过程当中
Alice是看不到Bob手里面所持有的钥匙长成什么样子的
所以在这个过程当中Alice看不到
所以Bob的一个0支
就是实现了对应的一个0支是性
那么接下来我们将会介绍对应的一个ZKP如何负能于区块链
那么在这个章节我们将会重点介绍ZKP的一个构造
还有目前常用的一个证明方式
我们叫做Commit and Approve
那么接下来我们就来看一下对应的目前常用的一个ZKP的一个构造
那么目前ZKP的一个设计方式主要是依赖于三个重要的一个源域
分别是多项式的一个IOP
然后是多项式的一个承诺
简称为Polynomial Commitment Scan 又简称为PCS
最后使用到的是Fitt-Chamille的一个转换
那么证明者在PiOP这样的一个阶段
会向验证者发送一个Polynomial的一个Oracle
那么多项式的IOP的一个全称叫做Polynomial Interactive Oracle Proof
在这个过程当中证明者会将这样的一个多项式封装成一个黑盒
然后验证方可以像这样的一个黑盒去做一些问询
有限制的问询
那么这个问询一般是一个随机点
比如说我们的验证方在左图当中可以像这样的一个Px的一个黑盒
去询问相应的一个Alpha
然后这样的一个黑盒它就会和验证方做一个交互
然后会将这样的一个Palpha返回给对应的一个验证方
那么在这个过程当中
Polynomial它始终会诚实地向验证方去告诉它
最终Px在x的一个Alpha点的这样的一个Palpha的一个值
但是在目前实际生活场景当中
这样的一个Oracle它是不存在的
所以我们这个时候就需要将Oracle给干掉
那么如何把Oracle给替换掉呢
那么在这里面就需要引入的是一个多项式承诺方案
那么在多项式承诺方案当中
验证方和证明方是需要去执行这样的一系列的CGMA协议
去实现左边的PiOP的这样的一个性质的
那么在这个证明者当中
我们的证明者首先会去发送这样的一个Px
也就是它对应的需要证明的这样一个多项式的承诺
然后把这个承诺值公开
那么承诺值一旦公开以后
后续所有的运算和验证过程
还有生成证明的过程
它都很难去改变这样的一个承诺值内部所存在的
这样的一个多项式
然后验证者在这里面
接下来在第二步就会去向证明者去发送一个问询
那么这个问询在CGMA协议里面
我们一般叫做随机挑战
英语是Random Challenge
然后这个证明者P
它就会去发送这样的一个多项式的运算
也就是Pα的这样的一个Evaluation的一个评估值
同时还会去生成对应的一个打开的一个证明
叫做Open Proof
然后这个Open Proof是可以让这样的验证方去验证
我这样的一个Pα确实适合我的这样的一个承诺值
还有我对应发送过来的这个α是唯一绑定的
但是我们可以看到
这样的一个多项式承诺
它是一个交互式证明系统
所以我们在SNARK当中是希望能够去实现一个
非交互式的一个证明系统
那么我们在这里面就可以将这个α
利用到这样的一个Filtres Mille做一个转换
那么在Filtres Mille当中
这个证明者就会去利用到一个RO
去计算就是将所有的Public Coin
全部输入到一个RO当中
去生成相应的这样的一个α
然后再将Pα和Pα发送给这样的一个验证方
我们这个证明者和验证者只需要进行一轮的通信
就可以让验证者去相信证明者
对应了这样的一个断言指针
那么ZKSNARK的一个优势就是在于说
它的一个验证速度比较快
然后证明的一个占用空间比较小
但是相对来说
它大量的时间都是在证明阶段
也就是证明者的一个在线阶段
会去消耗大量的一个算力
那么主要的算力来源是来源于两个部分
那么第一个复杂度的来源
就是在于说它需要对电路做一些抽象
那么电路抽象为多像是
大量需要利用到FFT的算法
那么如果是基于Sumcheck的这样的一些性质
也需要对电路本身
它需要利用到大量的一些运算
来形成相应的一个多像式
它的一个耗势是比较长的
第二个部分在基于比如说像IPA
或者像KZG的一个承诺方案当中
那么多像式的一个惩罚
还有橢圆矩线上像KZG IPA上面
需要利用到橢圆矩线
然后像单边的多像式里面
会需要利用到大量的一个多像式的一个惩罚操作
那么这一些操作都需要消耗大量的一个计算资源
那么接下来我将会给大家通过一个简单的例子
来介绍相应的这样的一个Commit and Approve
那么我们首先要证明的是
给大家说明的是什么是对应的Commit
那么Commit主要可以分为两个阶段
一个是Commit一个是Decormit
那么Decormit可以认为是
对应PCS当中的一个Prove的一个阶段
那么证明者需要先将自己需要承诺的这样的一个消息
M放到一个信封当中
因为信封的一个结构是公开的
然后信封内装到什么东西
在证明者打开之前是保密的
那么我们也可以知道
如果这个信封不被拆开
那么证明者很难去改变信封内的这样的一个信件
那么在Decormit也就是Prove阶段
验证者可以要求证明者去打开某一个信封
然后证明者就将这个信封当中的这个消息
给M打开
然后并且交给对应的一个验证方
去进行一个验证
那么我们通过一个简单的试验
来给大家介绍一下
Commit and Approve的这样的一个paradigm
也就是目前常用的一个设计范氏
刚刚所介绍到的PiOPPCS和Filtres and Mia转换
其实它的一个主要的一个来源
就是在于它的Commit and Approve
那么我们在这里面假设左边有一个算数电路
那么这个算数电路仅有两个门构成
那么我们在这里面
主要是它的输入是A1,B1和C1
然后还有AR,B2和
然后它最后的这样的一个输出是一个CR
那么在协议执行之前
我们整个证明者
验证者和证明者
他也只能看到对应的电路的一个拓补结构
但是我们的验证者是不知道
A1,B1,AR,B2,还有C1,CR
这里的6个值的一个具体内容是什么
那么在具体内容公开之前
我们首先证明者
Ka可以先对每一个Wire
也就是说它每一个输入引脚和输出引脚
去选择一个对应的Renderness
然后将这个Renderness
唯一的一个Renderness
然后接下来就是这个Wire和Renderness做一个集连
去经过一个Random Oracle
会得到对应的每一个Wire的一个Commitment
然后我们在这里面
就将对应的这样的一个Commitment给公开
也就是Ca1,CR,CB1,CB2
CCE和CC2的这样的6个的Commitment只给公开
也就是一个Wire对应一个Renderness
然后每一个Wire和Renderness对应
唯一的一个Commitment
然后接下来我们验证方就可以让证明方
去发送相应的一些随机挑战
然后这样的一个
比如说我们的验证方需要先让对应的证明方
先去打开对应的一个加法门的这样的一个信息
那么在这里面
我们的例子是不考虑对应的一个领知性的
所以我们在这里面的一个打开方式
就可以直接将信封当中
也就是它Commitment里面的这样的一个内容给直接打开
那么比如说我们在这里面
需要先去证明第一个门电路
也就是证明者在这里面去
需要生成几个证明
首先它需要先将对应的C1,CR,C1,AR,AR,R,CR,CR
这样的4个值给扔出去给打开
然后将对应的每一个Wild的影角的一个输入输出值
还有它对应的这样的一个Randomness给公开
然后公开给验证方
然后验证方在这里面就可以去验证C1和A1,B1
是否是满足这样的一个加法关系的
同样我们可以重新的让验证方去计算
这样的一个Random Oracle的一个值
然后将C1将每一个影角和它对应的Randomness做一个集联
经过一个RO去验证说我这样的一个东西之间的一个关联性
也就是间接的去验证我的Commitment
和我的一个输入输出之间的一个对应关系
然后因为A1和B1在host的运算当中
它将不再使用了
我们就可以将A1和B1从这样的一个空间当中
给内存当中给释放出来
然后来降低对应的一个Prove Generation当中所使用到的
一个内存的一个开销
那么同样在证明这样的一个惩罚门里面
我们需要让这个证明方去打开相应的一个CAR
CBR和CCR也就是分别对应的是AR,BR和CR的一个承诺
然后它的那么如何打开呢
那么在这里面我们就可以将AR,BR,CR
和它相对应的一个Renderness RAR,RBR和RCR
这样的6个Wire值和对应的Renderness给打开
然后有验证方去进行一个验证
同样验证方在这里面因为AR比RCR打开了
然后在这里面它也可以去验证对应的一个承法门的一个移植性
也就是去验证对应的这样的一个CR
等于AR成BR,AR等于C1
那么在这里面就证明完成了
然后我们值得注意的是
那么在一般的运算当中
一般的交互式证明协议当中
它的一个证明电路是非常庞大的
那么我们在这里面可以采用到的是
一个Cut and Choose的一个手段
去做一些随机的一些验证
也就是我们的验证方可以去发送固定个
就是比如说AR发个这样的一个门电路
然后要求证明者对这AR发个门电路做一个打开
然后这样它就可以不需要去验证整个门电路
然后可以仅验证相应的一些Transcript
也就是相应的一些门电路的一个输入输出
当中的一个移植性
还有和对应的Commitment的当中的移植性
然后来几大的降低对你的Proof Generation的一个开销
那么我们接下来回到
对你的Commit and Approve for Snark的这样的一个内容
那我们就可以看到在整个现在的Snark的一个设计言语当中
那么主要是由PiOp PCS和Filth-Chamilla Transformation
三方面做一个展开
那么在PiOp for Secute里面
它是利用对应的一个约束系统
比如说像R1CS像Plunkish或者像Air
对电路做一个编码
然后得到一系列的Prover polynomial
我一般将它叫为证明者多像式
然后有了这些证明者多像式
也就是相当于是对前面的
就是前面例子当中的一个电路的一个编码
然后我们有了这一些编码以后
我们接下来就可以利用到PCS for PiOp
对编码后的多像式
选用合适的一个方式进行承诺
然后拿来生成证明
然后这个过程其实也就对应的是刚刚的两个部分
第一个就是承诺的一个发送
然后第二个就是承诺的一个打开
然后在这个过程当中
它需要由证明者去生成对应的一个证明
然后来证明起运算的一个证确性
然后我们也可以看到刚刚的这样的一个IP的一个协议
一个协议是一个交互式证明协议
所以在这个过程当中
我们要实现对应的SNARC
也就是Succinct Interactive的这样一个性质
我们需要利用到Fittler-Mill的一个转换
然后在这里面利用到
随机与延机替换交互过程当中的这些随机数
然后来实现一个非交互式的证明
那么从刚刚这样的一个内容就可以看出来
我们这样的一个协议
它其实是主要的来源
它的paradigm的一个来源是来源与对应的commit
and prove的一个paradigm
然后来实现对应的一个ZKSNARC
最后我将给大家介绍ZKP在区块链当中的一些应用
那么我们现在团队之内主要完成的三大类的一些工作
主要两大类的工作主要是分布式的一个身份认证DID
和对应的一些0G证明的一个虚拟机的一些工作
那么在分布式身份认证的DID当中
通常其实是对标与对应的一个中心化的一个身份认证
那么在中心化的一个身份认证当中
通常需要有一个trusted的一个server
或者是一个centralized的一个server
需要提供对应那个服务
那么它这个时候要求中端也就是点对点的进行一个服务
点对点的让服务器和云客户端之间有一个对应的一个
一般是区别于对应的一个中心化的一个服务器
那么在分布式的一个身份认证当中
那么主要的一个开销就是在于它的端侧
那么在这里面主要是分为三大类的一个实体
分成发行者 证明者和验证者
那么发行者在这里面需要对证明者去发行这样的一个评证
那么证明者会向发行者去请求这样的一个评证
那么在使用这样的一个评证的时候
验证者也就是服务提供商
需要对证明者发送过来的一个评证做一些验证
那么在这个过程当中我们是需要有一个可信的一个数据管理系统的
也就是说我们的证明者的一些标识服信息
和证明者对应的这样的一个potential的评证信息
都是需要存储在一个区块链
可信的三方或者是一个分布式的一个服务器上
那么这个是分布式身份认证的这样的一个
基于W3C的一个标准
DID的一个标准
那么基于刚刚所介绍的这样的一个图的一个模型呢
我在这里面就将对应的一个角色分配和流程的一个简介放在这里
那么角色分配里面证明者他是一个凭证的一个拥有者
颁发者是凭证的负责对应的生辰
凭证的生辰和对应的一个凭证的一个颁发
验证者一般是验证证明者的一个身份
然后去提供一个服务
那么对应的一个流程主要在于凭证的一个签发
证明者会通过ZKP等手段向颁发者去提出一个凭证请求
那么同样的颁发者也可以通过
像一些中心化的一些CA机构
可以直接对证明者去提供一个可信的一个凭证
那么如果是基于0支持证明的话
这一个假设就可以加上一些开销
然后替换为证明者向颁发者提供请求
那么证明者在这里面可能会需要去撤销
或者对一些信息更新
那么颁发者就会对应地去进行一些删除或者更新凭证
也就是在第三方的blockchain
或者他自己本地存储的这样的一个list上面
去做一些信息的更新
那么在凭证的使用当中
证明者会和验证者做一些身份的一些交互
还有一些信息的交互
然后由证明者去证明这样的一个凭证的一个合法性
那么目前分布式身份认证通常是这样的一些架构图
那么基于0支持证明的ZKDID
它的一个一些基础基础有共识机制
那么共识机制它主要是可以用了
包括分布式存储 分布式网络
这些都可以分别用来纯处
分别可以用来约束它一个存储的一个准确证确性
数据存储的一个准确性
那么数字签名和0支持证明
是实现过删除的一个验证
签发管理以及更新的一些重要手段
那么ZKVM它可以将一些非常复杂的一些言语
比如说它底层需要去写一些电路
那么可以将这一些非常复杂的电路
直接利用到high-level的一些program
比如说像Rust的语言 像C++语言
直接转换成对应的一个底层电路
然后直接是ZKP可用
那么在需求方面
主要是分布式的一个身份认证
可追溯性和用户的一个隐私保护
那么在匿名评证当中
这个就需要去实现对你这个匿名性
那么在大部分场景下面的匿名性是一个可选项
因为一般找实现可验证性即可
那么在应用协议方面
通常可以采用到
像DIZK通用的一些分布式的一些领知证明系统
然后匿名评证 专用的一些领知证明协议
来加速领知证明的一个效率
那么合规和应用场景上面
其实主要是对应的隐私保护
链上的一个高效验证
分布式的一个身份管理和一个数据的一个可追溯性
那么应用场景
包括证物金融智能体的A证证之间的一个身份验证
和公民的一个网络电子身份标识
那么主要的两个技术路径
主要是包括领知证明
和可信的一个分布式的一个数字身份
那么领知
所以一般的很多项目
其实在区块链上面
都不有对应的一个分布式的一个身份认证
然后做相应的一些存储
然后在这个领知证明里面
就会
它是一个主要的一个技术路径
那么DID的设计
主要是分为平正发行
平正管理和平称的使用
那么我在这里面
罗列了目前常用的一些技术
那么在平正的发行当中
主要是基于数字签名
领知证明会更多一些
然后基于不同的属性
还有基于不同的需求
我们可以采用不同的
类型的一些数字签名
然后在平称的管理里面
我们通常有三种
第一种就是基于7e的一个可信之心环境
来存储所有的一个平正
和对应的一个DID的一个
就是它的identifier的一个ID信息
那么也可以利用中心化的服务器
来用于斑发 撤销和更新DID
然后可以作为一个对应的一个可信节点
也可以利用到像区块链
这一等分布式的一个系统
然后平称的状态和公要的信息
存储于一个分布式的账本当中
那么它就具有对应的不可篡改和可追溯性
那么在平称的使用当中
我们也是有基于三大类
第一大类就是基于对应的数字签名
那么结构比较简单
第二个是根据选用的一个数字签名
算法设计专用的一个
领知证明的一个协议
来完成对应的一个证明
然后最后就是在23年发表
在itreboyspnp上面的
有一个ZKQ10这个文章
它里面主要是基于通用的一个领知证明
也就是说用户通过ZKP
生成不可伪造的证明
实现属性级别的一个验证
然后可以不暴露具体的一个信息
那么接下来我们来介绍一下
领知证明的一个虚拟机
那么在领知证明的一个虚拟机
我们可以将高级语言
比如说像Rust 像Go
像C++的这样的一些高级语言
可以不用
利用到Sercum的一些
low-level的一些电路语言
转换为对应的一个电路
然后再实现证明
它对开发者更加地友好
它会利用到编译原理当中的一些知识
然后将high-level的一些program
然后基于不同的ISC转换成
也就是它的一个指令机
转换为相应的一个可执行编码
也可以认为是一个会编语言
然后Executor就会利用到
就会基于ISC和不同的一个计算机架构
比如说像焚弩伊曼架构
像Halfo架构去执行相应的一个
就是调用Executor去执行这个程序
然后再扔到一个去生成一个trace
然后扔到prover里面
这个prover就会将对应的trace里面的约束信息
利用到不同的约束系统和IOP的一些
DK Snark协议去生成对应的一个约束
然后多像是
然后调用不同的一个prover算法
去生成对应的一个proof
然后这个proof就可以上练
然后由不同的用户可以在练上
直接快速的去进行一些验证
然后ZKVM的一个语言的一个high-level的一个作用
它可以将任何的一个高级语言
转换为电路语言
并且对应转换为一个简短的证明
然后在应用场景当中
就是说分布式
比如说像DID刚刚介绍的
分布式身份认证当中
我们通常会有不同的一个业务逻辑
我们的业务逻辑如果说
比如说大于18岁
比如说我们要去买酒
或者要买烟
我们就需要去向卖烟或者卖酒的地方
去证明我的身份是大于18岁的
然后在这个过程当中
大于18岁的这样的一个电路会比较复杂
然后我们就可以
利用到high-level的这样的一个Rust
或者像C++去将复杂的一些业务
做一些ZK化
然后调用ZKVM
可以将非常复杂的一个业务逻辑
压缩成一个非常简短
然后精看 短小的一个proof
然后验证方也不需要重新地
去执行这样的一个业务逻辑
然后就可以去验证
对应的这样的一个内容
它是正确的
那么ZKVM主要就分成三个模块
首先是指令级
然后是执行器executed
然后接下来就是证明算法Prover
那么指令级可以分成三大类
分别是标准指令级
比如说像Maps
像Risk5等标准指令级
可以实现VM的一些基本功能
那么还有ZK Friendly
领知证明友好的一些RSA
但是相对于标准RSA来说
VM的一个表达能力偏弱
但是它在生成领知证明的时候
可以提供更快的一个证明速度
还有一种就是类似于Open VM的一种混合RSA
可以在标准的RSA上面
去扩展一些特殊操作
增强RSA的一个表达能力
比如说我们可以在Risk5或者Maps上面
去加上像Pairing
像数字签名这样的一些
基本的一些密码学上常用的一些操作
那么在Executor里面
主要是基于不同的计算机架构
来进行设计
那么分为Fono Eman
Fono Eman里面内存和CPU是一体的
然后Halfor架构里面
内存和CPU它的一个运算是分离的
那么在混合架构里面
会去结合Fono Eman架构和Halfor架构
不同的一个优势
然后来设计新的一种架构
然后在Trace和电路里面
那么Executor会根据RSA
和计算机架构的一个运行逻辑
去生成对一个Trace
并且在Trace接下利用电路
利用不同的Circuit
来完成对一个约束
然后来证明ZKVM运行的一个证确性
然后在Prover里面
主要是由三方面的性能来决定
分为Field, PIOP和PCS
那么Field的大小
它直接决定了Prover的一个性能
那么比如说在一些特定的Field
比如说像Gody, Logs或者像Baby Bear
他们可能对64位或者32位的一个计算机
更友好
也就是说特定的一些Field
会对一些RSA的一些操作
它的一个兼容性更加
那么在PCIOP里面
目前常见的
可以分为SumTrack和Plonky3两种
那么SumTrack它支持分布式
然后在多机场景下
它的一个效率会更高
那么Plonky3
它需要执行大量的一个FFT操作
那么在PCS里面
它的KZG和IPCA
主要是在橢圆曲线上的一个操作
它的一个开销比较大
但是它的一个验证效率很高
那么Fryne它是一个后量子安全的
它的一个证明速度比较快
但是它的一个验证速度比较慢
所以后续在Fryne当中
通常需要利用到Recruising的
然后会去引入Grow16的这样的一个套路
然后去进一步的压缩Fryne的一个证明大小
然后右边
就是说本页的这个图
主要就是ZKVM的一个Trace的生成
然后对于Trace也会去
根据不同的一个运算
去进行一些Trace切分
比如说Arrestmatic的table
它就是对于加法门和乘法门等
Arrestmatic的一些运算做一些约束
像Control里面可能会对于
像Logic里面可能就会对于像
and XOR
然后像FL一些跳转指令
去进行一系列的约束
那么在Memory里面
比如说就有它的
就是比如说我的内存的一个读取
然后我把某一个值写入到内存
当中的某一块
然后这个部分呢
会去做一个table
然后最后会去调用
During Offline的Memory Checking
去检查Memory读和写的一个移植性
那么主要的实现方法
有Multi-setting
然后有基于Logup的Logup Argument的
还有基于像Promotation的这样的一些方法
那么最后呢
我将给大家介绍一些ZKV的一些其他的应用
那么ZKV的其他应用
比如说有反炸的一个风险评估
和医疗保险的一个电价
那么反炸风险评估当中呢
银行和电信的一个运营商呢
合作共同完成反炸风险评估
那么银行呢
会作为一个数据中心
然后电信的一个运营商呢
作为一个访问者
然后银行呢
可以根据电信营服运营商所提供的一个模型
然后呢再不泄漏
用户数据的一个情况下呢
提供易受诈骗的一个用户名单
然后在医疗保险定价方面呢
医疗医院呢
可以和保险机构合作
共同完成医疗保险的一个定价
那么在这里面呢
医院呢
作为一个数据中心
保险机构呢
作为一个访问者
然后呢
在医院呢
根据保险机构所提供的模型上面呢
可以再不泄漏医疗用户的
医疗的一个健康数据的一个情况下呢
提供对你的一个保险定价
那么同样呢
啊
基于林芝证明的一个
信息安全的一个管控框架呢
它可以在数据安全
保护数据安全的一个前提下呢
可以充分的一个挖掘数据的一个价值
那么在应用
它的一个应用范围很广
然后它的数据是最小化的
也就是说林芝证明呢
它适用于金融医疗
然后通信保险等多个领域
和它的行业
然后它的应用范围非常的广
然后呢
它也可以数据最小化
它可以在数据可用不可见的方面呢
在模型推理
模型分析等用途上面呢
可以直接
只把自己需要利用到的数据呢
给披露出来
然后呢
同样呢
这个披露的数据呢
可以利用到林芝证明当中这个
林芝信
然后呢
来形成相应的一个隐私保护
进而保护对应的一个数据安全
然后感谢大家的一个聆听